hi guys happy new year i know i'm a
little late on the happy new year
bandwagon but i've been really busy
playing video games so
here's my happy new year's video a
little bit late i hope you guys had an
awesome new year and a safe one at that
now everybody was making their recap
videos for 2010
but uh you know what i just made a
playlist so you can check that playlist
out here of some of my favorite videos
that i made in 2010. i would like to
know from you guys um what was your
favorite video that i made of 2010 and
not only your favorite video that i made
what was your favorite video overall
there's so many good videos
and
i'm gonna have to say that mine was uh
what do you think jenna what do you
think my favorite video was in 2010 come
on just guess
oh no shark week
not for me there's jenna she's over
there wait i what was the question my
question was what was your favorite
video of 2010
windows he's snatching your people up
trying to write them so you need to
hodge kids
hodge kids hodge what uh yeah was that
right yeah it was definitely my favorite
um the gregory brothers hilarious
antoine dodson
wow just wow
wow that's it for this little video just
a little update uh make sure you check
out the playlist
and let me know which your favorite
video was 2010 and here is to an awesome
2011. oh by the way
my eye is better
so get ready no more eye patch no more
creepy eye
i'm back
bye